the lawsuits against deshaun watson all
of which allege misconduct
during massage sessions now at 21.
a surprising statement emerged yesterday
afternoon from his lawyer rusty hardin
18 massage therapists with their names
attached
to statements of support for desean
watson
most of them don't mention the pending
lawsuits
some of them cross over into commenting
on the credibility
of the claims being made by the 21
plaintiffs
it's possible that all of them are
telling the truth we can't rule that out
it could be
there are 18 people out there who had no
bad experience with desean watson
and 21 others plus the 22nd person who
spoke to si.com and who's not yet sued
they could be telling the truth that
they had bad experiences that there were
things that happened that shouldn't have
happened
the big takeaway chris that a lot of
people have had
and this is where yet another rusty
hardened statement that they think is a
silver bullet becomes a boomerang yeah
why the prevailing reaction to this is
why does this guy have 40 different
massage therapists okay good
yeah that that's that's i i wondered
what you were going to say there
i haven't really paid attention to like
social media reaction and stuff like
that
but that was my initial reaction i mean
how many massage therapists does the
damn guy have
yeah it is weird now it doesn't mean
he's guilty or anything like that
it does not um but you know within
helping himself it
again is the second time where it raises
a few more questions too to just go
why can't we just have one or two
therapists and
they can massage the uncomfortable area
that
you know is is so talked about so much
and he's showing charts and everything
like that
so i'm with you mike that was uh you
know a little weird to me and
i i don't know what this means but i
guess it's a little positive publicity
for deshaun watson in this
public fight right now well and that's
one important thing to keep in mind
chris
this is all court of public opinion
stuff because
i was looking at the texas rules of
evidence which looked to be very similar
if not identical to the federal rules of
evidence in the west virginia rules of
evidence
and in civil cases it will be very
very very difficult for rusty harden
to bring on a parade of witnesses like
the seinfeld finale where it's
one massage therapist after another
saying he never did anything
improper with me he never did anything
improper with me
he never did anything improper with me
character
witnesses in civil cases for the most
part
are prohibited so and and it's it's
look it's a common sense reaction i mean
you bring in the branch manager of a
bank saying well he never robbed my bank
well okay we're not accusing him of
robbing your bank he's being accused of
robbing someone else's bank right that's
the question did he rob that bank the
question isn't did he rob your bank
and i think that's where this becomes in
a court of law a very difficult argument
to make but it's not about the court of
law it's about the court of public
opinion
but it feels like every time rusty
hardin issues a statement aimed at
helping desean watson in the court of
public opinion
there's something that swings back
around and creates
a caveat question a criticism and jermon
bushrod played for 12 years in the nfl
he tweeted yesterday
in response to our story with the hardin
statement he said i played 12 years i
think i had
half of that number of massage
therapists throughout my entire career
right
so that that underscores the natural
reaction that a lay person is going to
have why do you have 40 massage
therapists when you have a guy who
played in the nfl for 12 years with a
recognizable name
yeah say what the hell's up with this
that that just makes it
more natural and logical for people to
say what the hell's up with this no no
question i
you know i could speak to myself i mean
you know
one maybe two massage therapists right
in the area oh wait this
this guy does this woman this guy
doesn't he's not available
let me call the backup plan to see if
they can do that i mean really that's
i think that's pretty you know standard
for for most nfl players is to have that
one
maybe two person you don't even trust a
lot of times
like different strangers to touch you
it's like you got to get in the trust
tree
and you got to be able to you know rub
me the right way and massage me the
right way to where i i don't
wake up the next morning and go wait i
feel worse and things like that you know
players are picky with that type of
stuff
so yeah it was
a nice attempt in the the court of
public opinion but
to me it's like they can't win that war
right now
it's over like they were too late to
react to all of this
that's where i look at it and just go
busby and company
just came out swinging i mean just
right hook uppercut left uppercut we're
throwing haymakers
and watson and his team were in the
corner just taking blows doing the
rope-a-dope here for a while
and just receiving it and and now i feel
like it's going to be too hard
really to overturn the the public
opinion and how everybody feels about it
but there's also a chance that busby's
gonna pull the daniel jones and trip
over the five-yard line
given what we talked about yesterday
that statement from the other night
trying to explain why he ultimately is
not even though he said multiple times
he was
going to why he's not submitting
evidence to the houston police
department
to support a potential criminal
prosecution art acevedo who's the
outgoing houston police chief and i
can't tell whether he's already gone
or whether he's just on the way of
heading to miami for the same job the
way he posted a tweet yesterday in
response to our story
about busby's latest comments it created
the impression he's not gone yet
acevedo made it clear we're ready to
investigate all allegations
mr busby can cast all the baseless
assertions about the hard-working men
and women of the houston police that he
wants he can't run away
from history and the truth of the
professionalism of our men and women we
stand ready to investigate
and and i look i look at it this way the
claim by busby that
there's some bias against him or some
bias in favor of rusty hardin who
represents desean watson
that will prevent the houston police
department from properly investigating
21
claims of sexual misconduct
if he truly believes that that he's an
impediment he should withdraw
he should get somebody else to represent
these 21 people because he's undermining
the efforts of his clients to get
complete justice if he truly believes it
and even if he doesn't withdraw those 21
individuals should hire a different
lawyer
if their lawyer is an impediment to
their effort to get complete justice if
he truly believes it
if he doesn't believe it he's just
trying to create a safe harbor
for never following through on his
threat to go to the police
because he knows that
a contest of what happened between two
people in a room with no witnesses and
no objective proof to tilt it one way or
the other is never going to result in a
prosecution
but he wants to create the sense right
that there could be a prosecution
because it makes the cases look stronger
if you're saying
we're going to take this to the police
oh wait we're not going to take it to
police
but not because we have any concerns
about whether or not there would be
a justifiable prosecution we have
concerns about
the the police not liking me
that that so either he should stand down
because he really is an impediment
to his clients getting justice or he's
just pretending that
to be the case so he can justify not
going to police either way he's got a
problem with that
one that one that i think the average
person isn't really going to notice
but it's just another reason why chris i
got a problem with the way he's handled
this yeah
that has nothing to do with whether or
not his clients are telling the truth
i don't like his tactics i don't like
his methods and i really don't like
what he did the other night by trying to
create this false narrative as to why he
wouldn't go to the police yeah well i
have a hard time believing that this is
the first time tony busby's rubbed
people the wrong way i mean he's rubbed
us
wrong way here from the start and that's
not letting off desean watson off the
hook
in any you know shape way or form it's
that yeah
you know busby has got a a very
flamboyant
in your face condescending way he talks
and delivers statements and things so uh
i'm sure there is a history who knows
with him in the houston police
no the mike here's what i want to ask
you i mean
it again like i don't have experience
here
should houston police be investigating
this at this point would this be normal
for them to be doing this if this was
like johnny common citizen
well number one they don't know who the
people are yeah right at some point
the person who's the victim of the crime
has to initiate the process
of alerting the authorities to the fact
that there is a crime and just because
there are 22 lawsuits filed under a
pseudonym
that's not going to activate law
enforcement
in and of itself at some point there has
to be something
that they can say we we we have an
obligation to look into this and
typically it involves the victim or the
alleged victim
picking up the phone or going to the
police station
and starting the process of of
triggering an investigation and then the
appropriate individuals decide whether
or not they're going to pursue criminal
charges so
i just think in this case my opinion is
and this is an opinion yeah i think
busby wanted to huff and puff about
prosecution
to seal off the argument that was being
raised in the court of public opinion
and i don't like this argument
but it was being raised in the court of
public opinion why didn't any of these
people go straight to the police
a lot of people will raise that issue
you don't have to go straight to the
police right and there are reasons why
people don't go straight to the police
that doesn't make their their stories
untrue but in an effort to prop
up the alleged victims and give them
that
explanation busby i think is he's gone
too far with this oh we're going to the
police we're going to the police we're
going to the place oh wait a minute
here's why we're not going to the police
right and
i i don't like it and the last word
about busby i mean look the bottom line
is if you're an effective lawyer
you will piss a lot of people off yeah
that's right i know i know trust me yeah
sorry london
but we know i deal with everyone every
day
you are not if you are not pissing
people off when you're practicing law
you are
doing it wrong
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports